[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und ein gutes
neues Jahr wünsche ich Ihnen Rudi zerne
sicher auch unbedingt gutes neues Jahr
und guten Abend schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen von diesem 1
Januar Deutschland startet ins neue Jahr
ohne größere Ausschreitungen dennoch
gibt es Angriffe auf Einsatzkräfte und
Festnahmen schweres Erdbeben in Japan
tausende Haushalte sind ohne Strom eine
Tsunamiwarnung haben die Behörden
inzwischen
herabgestuft und Gesamtführung
verteidigt Andreas Wellinger wird
Dritter beim Neujahrsspringen der vier
schanzentournee in gamischparten
Kirchen die Silvesternacht in
Deutschland blieb friedlicher als
befürchtet der Trend zu immer mehr
Gewalt habe erstmal gebrochen werden
habe erstm s gebrochen werden können
heißt es von der Gewerkschaft der
Polizei allerdings gab es mehrere
tödliche Unfälle mit silvesterkrachern
und wieder wurden Einsatzkräfte mit
Böllern beschossen aus der Hauptstadt
berichtet Stefanie gargosch Böller
Verbotszonen Kontrollen tausende von
Polizisten im Einsatz in Berlin vor
allem aber auch bundeswald die Bilanz
bisher so chaotisch wie letztes Jahr
wurde es nicht der Ausnahmezustand blieb
aus viele Bilder aber weiter
beunruhigend allein in der Haupt stad
wurden 54 Polizisten verletzt stand
jetzt ich verurteile das aufs Schärfste
was dort wieder passiert ist insgesamt
war es aber ruhiger als letztes Jahr das
heißt man sieht dass es geholfen hat
einen immensen Personal Aufwand zu
betreiben und ich erwarte jetzt aber
auch und das ist mein Appell auch an die
Justiz dass die Taten die passiert sind
auch sehr
stark verfolgt und auch konsequent
geandet werden in Berlin mehr
Strafverfahren mindestens 700
weil die Polizei schneller und härter
Durchgriff dennoch branten wieder Autos
beschossen sich vor allem junge Männer
gerade am Alexanderplatz positiv
Rettungskräfte Feuerwehr konnten wohl
erfolgreich von der Polizei geschützt
werden was neu war in diesem Jahr war
dass wir nicht mehr so schwere Angriffe
hatten es waren vornehmlich ja
böllerwürfe oder Beschüsse auf fahrende
Fahrzeuge soass zum Glück in diesem Jahr
keine einzige Kraft nach jetzigem Stand
verletzt wurde die Mehrheit der
Deutschen feierte friedlich ob hier oder
anderswo mit Familie Freunden und auch
manchmal allein Feier habe ich auf der
Couch zu Hause ganz ruhig ganz ruhig nur
wir zwei ganz klassisch mit der Familie
anstoßen um 12 Uhr und relativ zeitig
ins Bett über Stunden leuchtete der
Himmel über der Hauptstadt mit einer
riesigen Party vor dem Brandenburger Tor
und jeder Menge guter Wünsche für das
Jahr
2024 im Zusammenhang mit den
Terrorwarnungen für den Kölner Dom hat
die Polizei in Bochum am Silvesterabend
einen weiteren Mann festgesetzt damit
sind jetzt fünf Verdächtige in Gewahrsam
am Dom bleiben die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
erstmal bestehen seit Weihnachten sind
dort Beamte im Einsatz die Behörden
prüfen Hinweise auf ein islamistisches
Netzwerk das einen Anschlag geplant
haben
soll zur Hochwasserlage in Deutschland
da hat der nachlassende Regen vieler
Orts die Situation etwas entspannt in
Teilen Niedersachsens gelten allerdings
weiterhin Hochwasserwarnungen auch weil
neuer Dauerregen droht in Oldenburg soll
jetzt eine mobile Deichanlage die Stadt
vor den Wassermassen schützen
bundesinnenministerin fäer machte sich
am Nachmittag ein Bild von der Lage etwa
600 Menschen die vor dem neuen Deich
wohnen müssen möglicherweise evakuiert
werden das Ergebnis der
Mitgliederbefragung der FDP ist da eine
knappe Mehrheit will in der
Ampelkoalition bleiben
52% stimmten dafür die Regierungsarbeit
mit SPD und Grünen fortzusetzen an der
Befragung beteiligte sich gut ein
Drittel der rund 72 000 Parteimitglieder
FDP Generalsekretär jir Sarai sagte die
Mitglieder wünschten sich eine klare
liberale Handschrift in der
Regierungspolitik in Japan hat das neue
Jahr mit einem schweren Erdbeben
begonnen in der Stärke
7,6 das Epizentrum lag in geringer Tiefe
in der Region noto in der Präfektur
Ishikawa die nationale Wetterbehörde
hatte eine Tsunamiwarnung für die
Küstenregion ausgegeben das Beben
zerstörte Häuser und Stromleitungen
mindestens zwei Menschen starben über
den aktuellen Stand Elisabeth
Schmidt es ist dieser Moment als kurz
nach 16 Uhr die Erde bebt als Gebäude
einstürzen Straßen aufreißen und
Menschen sich versuchen in Sicherheit zu
bringen dieser Moment der mit großer
Wucht in Japan traumatische Erinnerungen
wachrüttelt an das Beben Tsunami und die
Atomkatastrophe von Fukushima
2011 nach dem Beben heute trafen die
ersten Tsunamiwellen schon nach 2 3
Minuten auf
Land die Behörden warnen zunächst vor 5
m hohen Wellen sie fallen deutlich
kleiner aus obwohl die Erde an diesem
Neujahrstag mehr als 20 mal bebt alles
wackelt Einrichtung Ziegel fallen
herunter treffen Menschen nach Fukushima
gab es viel Kritik an Behörden und
Medien zu wenig sei damals gewarnt
worden diesmal ist der Appell im
Fernsehen eindringlich evakuieren sie
sofort etwa 97000 Menschen in Neu
Präfekturen sind aufgerufen ihre Häuser
zu
verlassen sein sie äußerst vorsichtig
diese Woche kann es weitere Beben der
Stärke 7 geben sei sie in den nächsten
Tagen besonders
wachsam Japan hat viel investiert in
Erdbebenschutz und Frühwarnsysteme und
doch ist die Lage unübersichtlich einige
Regionen sind nach wie vor schwer
zugänglich für die Rettungskräfte für
viele Menschen in Japan hat das neue
Jahr mit einem großen Schrecken
begonnen in Israel hat das Oberste
Gericht ein wichtiges Element der
umstrittenen Justizreform gekippt die
Richter erklärten eine Gesetzesänderung
fürnichtig die im Sommer verabschiedet
worden war das geänderte Gesetz hatte
dem Gericht die Möglichkeit genommen
Entscheidungen der Regierung im Zweifel
zu stoppen gegen die von der
rechtsnationalen Regierung
vorangetriebene Justizreform hatten
monatelang hunderttausende Menschen
protestiert Israels Armee stellt sich
auf einen längeren Krieg im Gazastreifen
ein einige Reservisten dürften deshalb
jetzt eine Kampf Pause einlegen teilte
ein Militärsprecher mit in der
Silvesternacht feuerte die Hamas erneut
zahlreiche Raketen auf Israel ab unter
anderem auf Tel Aviv auch das
israelische Militär setzte seine
Angriffe fort dabei soll ein Hamas
Kommandeur getötet worden
sein und auch der Krieg in der Ukraine
dauert an Russland hat seinen Nachbarn
in der Silvesternacht wieder heftig
bombardiert und auch heute die
Drohnenangriffe auf die Haup Stadt Kiev
fortgesetzt in Odessa wurden beim
Angriff auf ein Wohngebiet ein Mensch
getötet und mehrere verletzt in seiner
Neujahrsbotschaft dankte Präsident
selenski seinen Landsleuten für ihren
durchhaltewien und versprach neue Waffen
für die ukrainische
Armee es gehört zu den festen Regeln der
EU alle sech Monate übernimmt ein
Mitgliedsland den Ratsvorsitz bis
Mitternacht war das Spanien jetzt ist
Belgien dran und muss vermitteln z.B im
Streit über die Ukraine helfen außerdem
ist im Juni Europawahl Gunar Krüger hat
mehr eine Lasershow in Brüssel
silvesternach Belgien übernimmt die EU
Ratspräsidentschaft das heißt das Land
empfängt die Minister und setzt die
Agenda doch die präsidente des
Europaparlaments mahnte schon im Juni
ist Europawahl und was bis dahin nicht
beschlossen ist
verfällt es müssen noch insgesamt 150
Gesetze fertig werden also kein
Druck Belgiens premier de Cro muss
lachen jetzt werden wir nervös nein wir
freuen uns darauf Belgien hat die
Ratspräsidentschaft zum 13 mal inne wir
sollten also wissen was wir
tun zuun bleibt was aus dem
asylpakt spürbare Politik werden auch
als wahlkampfargument gegen Konkurrenz
von ganz rechts steigende Anteile von
Rechtsradikalen von politischen Kräften
die die Zusammenarbeit in Europa und
auch im Europäischen Parlament im
Grundsatz in Frage stellen und diese
Zusammenarbeit nicht wollen sind da
schwere Belastung für die Zukunft die
nächsten 5 Jahre für die Zukunft Europas
Europas Gegenwart belastet Viktor Orban
Sondergipfel am 1 Februar und der Ungar
blockiert noch immer Finanzhilfen für
die
Ukraine das können die europäischen
Staaten rein theoretisch auch mit 26
also ohne orbahn aber langfristig muss
das Problem einfach gelöst werden wir
können uns nicht weiterhin von Viktor
Orban erpressen lassen vielleicht hilft
ja Belgiens Erfahrung mit
Ratspräsidentschaften er recht beim
Blick auf den Nachfolger denn der heißt
Ungarn Papst franziskus hat in der
Neujahrsmesse im Petersdom die Bedeutung
von Frauen für die Kirche und für die
Welt betont Aufgabe aller Gesellschaft
en sei es jede Frau zu respektieren zu
schützen und zur Geltung kommen zu
lassen die Welt habe es nötig auf die
Mütter und Frauen zu schauen um Frieden
zu finden und um aus den Spiralen der
Gewalt und des Hasses auszubrechen sagte
franziskus am heutigen katholischen
Weltfriedenstag Frieden ist mit
Sicherheit einer der größten Wünsche
fürs neue Jahr das rund um die Welt mit
großer Freude und Feuerwerken begrüßt
wurde Volker dutchck hat die schönsten
Bilder der
Silvesternacht küssen hat noch nie
geschadet vor allem beim Start in ein
neues Jahr am timesquare New York
stellten sich hertausende dem Konfetti
Regen bei Temperaturen um 0° schalte der
Evergreen New York New York durch die
Häuser
Schluchten mit nassen Füßen ins neue
Jahr in Brasilien ist das nicht
unangenehm in Rio de Janeiro wie immer
viele Touristen Bein
von Feuerwerk und Lebensfreude an der
kppa
Cabana ich habe keine Worte um zu
beschreiben was ich gerade gesehen habe
die Energie der Menschen
unglaublich auch am Triumphbogen in
Paris bunte Laser und Böller ein
bisschen Ablenkung in weltweit unruhigen
Zeiten auch in Athen zu Füßen der
Akropolis Hunderttausende auf den
Straßen in Rom in London nahe dem
Riesenrad zählten die Schaulustigen bei
den Glocken von B Ben laut
mit vor 100 Jahren hatte die BBC zum
ersten Mal live das gelut zum
Jahreswechsel übertragen in schivening
in den Niederlanden begrüßten wieder
10000 badegäe das neue Jahr mit einem
Sprung in die
Nordsee nach ein paar Gläsern Wein wurde
ich gestern gefragt ob ich mitkommen
will ich habe ja gesagt jetzt muss ich
wohl eine Aktion bei der man schnell Mut
mit Leichtsinn verwechseln kann die
Nordsee hatte mittags nämlich nur 7°
aber Spaß hat es offensichtlich
gemacht ja und wach macht es auch große
Begeisterung löst weiterhin Andreas
Wellinger aus ne genau der Traum vom
toureseg lebt bei ihm jedenfalls Andreas
Wellinger hat beim neujahrsspringender
vichanzenournee in gamischpartenkirchen
Platz 3 belegt und seine Führung in der
Gesamtwertung verteidigt damit so der
28-Jährige aus rupholding fahre er mit
einem sehr guten Gefühl zum dritten
Springen nach
Innsbruck auch wenn es nicht ganz zum
Sieg gereicht hat Andreas wellingers
Platz 3 beschert ihm und den 21 000 im
Stadion zum neuen Jahr beste Laune zwei
erneut weite Sprünge auf 138 und
137inhalb Meter vor allem mit guter
sicherer Landung ermöglichen den
Podestplatz und den weiteren Traum vom
Gesamtsieg es war sehr sehr guter Start
ins neue Jahr ich freue aufbruck und
behofen ich hoff dass wir fre Wettkämpfe
haben dass dann wirklich der beste
Schispringer gewinnt und und von dem her
würde ich sagen Ausgangsposition ist gut
weitermachen den Tagessieg sichert sich
der slowener Anel lanisek vor wellingers
ergstem Konkurrenten um die
Gesamtführung dem Japaner rioyo
Kobayashi dieser liegt nur 1,8 Punkte
also ca 1 m hinter Wellinger morgen geht
es Innsbruck weiter mit der
Qualifikation und auch die Frauen sind
gesprungen eva pinkelnick hat am
Neujahrstag das zweite springen der
sogenannten two nights Tour in Obersdorf
gewonnen die Österreicherin setzte sich
vor abigil straight aus Kanada und ihrer
Landsfrau Jacqueline Seifriedsberger
durch gamischsiegerin Nik preutz
entschied die Gesamtwertung für sich
beste deutsche Agnes Reisch auf Platz
11 und Ski Langläuferin Victoria karl
hat bei der Tour des Ski erneut eine
beeindruckende Leistung abgeliefert beim
Verfolgungsrennen über 20 km in Toblach
wurde die Olympiasiegerin zweite und
verteidigte ihren Podestplatz in der
Gesamtwertung bei den Männer hatte
Friedrich moch Platz 6 beliiegt es
siegte der Norweger Harald omunsen
Östberg und das deutsche tennisd Angeli
Kerber und Alexander zwerev muss beim
United Cup in Australien um den
Viertelfinaleinzug bangen nach zwerfs
Sieg und kerbers Niederlage in den
einzelnen unterlagen sie im
entscheidenden Doppel gegen Frankreich
mit 6:7 6:2 und 10:12 die Entscheidung
übers Weiterkommen fällt am Mittwoch
wenn Frankreich auf Italien trifft
das war's von mir Danke Schön gerne
Vorsicht beim Wetter da wird vor
ergiebigem Dauerregen in den
Mittelgebirgen gewarnt und zwar von
heute Nacht bis Donnerstag auch im Rest
des Landes bringen viele Wolken morgen
kräftigen und lang anhaltenden Regen bei
4 bis 13° wird es sehr windig mit
stürmischen böhnen wir sagen tschüss und
wünschen Ihnen allen einen guten Start
ins neue Jahr um 11:15 Uhr gibt's hier
wieder Nachricht und jetzt können Sie
mit einer Terra x Doku in die Welt der
Elefanten an den Victoria Falls
eintauchen bis morgen wenn Sie
[Musik]
mögen